[Music]  my dad's acting like he didn't commit  all those crimes like he didn't write  that horrible letter threatening my mom  which I didn't testify on his behalf  you saved the letter right I mean you  can show it to your mom I can and she  probably shouldn't know about it but  that feels like the nuclear option she  sees that letter she leaves him it would  mean the end of the lunch time the state  hey what are you doing in those uniforms  I got them from my mom from when she  worked here we were gonna volunteer to  be your waitresses for free don't eat  waitresses if there are any customers  well this is just a dry spell pop it  will pass I went to the bank take out a  second mortgage to tide me over they  said no been doing business with  Riverdale national for 60 years they  said I was too high-risk you imagine  banks saying that about me wait pop what  can we do how can we help you help after  the article your mother wrote attacking  the diner  you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]